A new era has dawned.
A little miracle of technology - the
atomic power stations are going up.
We're bombarded with radiation
all the time...
...from everyday objects
like a watch.
Most people think that radioactive
waste is some kind of...
...but in actual fact, it looks a
little bit like this - black glass.
It will be radioactive
for hundreds of thousands of years,
and this is why we really need to
think about its long-term future.
The danger of radioactive waste
is here today,
and goes on and on tomorrow.
In full operation,
it will supply electricity
for a million people.
Climate change, the gases
blamed for global warming,
are pumped out in ever bigger
quantities.
The window of time to mitigate
the climate crisis
is shrinking by the day, really.
The problem is how to reduce
greenhouse gases.
Nuclear power
has a long proven record
as a non-fossil energy source.
Nuclear energy is not a solution
to climate change.
Nuclear energy
has a fraught history.
Greeted with optimism in the 1950s,
its reputation was clouded
by atomic bomb tests
and disasters like Chernobyl,
but as global leaders
work to tackle climate change,
nuclear power's allure
has come full circle.
Once up and running,
nuclear power stations
emit no carbon dioxide
or other greenhouse gases,
and nuclear's constant
energy generation sets it apart
from renewable sources of energy,
whose output can vary.
For the past 60 years or so,
it has provided
a very important type
of electricity, which we call...
That's the type of electricity
that guarantees that 24/7,
no matter when you want to
flip on or off your light switch,
the lights will be there.
The inherent dangers
of nuclear energy
make it a controversial
energy source,
and not everyone agrees
it's worth the risks it brings.
Nearly all of our nuclear waste
is at coastal sites
in one way or the other.
These are locations that are liable
to coastal processes,
storm surges, sea-level rise.
Those are highly vulnerable
to the worst impacts of
climate change that we can foresee.
I'm concerned
about the dangers it poses.
In 2011, a devastating earthquake
and tsunami in Japan led to meltdown
at the Fukushima Daiichi
nuclear reactor.
As a result of
the Fukushima accident,
both Japan and Germany,
for different reasons,
have decided to shut down rapidly
their national
nuclear energy output.
They ramped up coal and gas output
for a few years after the accident.
Dr Kharecha's research found
that there were health consequences
linked to this reduction
in the use of nuclear energy,
as both countries increased
their use of fossil fuels
in subsequent years.
As a direct
yet unintended consequence
of their decision to drastically
reduce their nuclear power output,
after the Fukushima accident,
both Japan and Germany together
lost the opportunity to prevent
over 28,000 air-pollution-induced
premature deaths
that were as a result
of fossil fuel power use.
Japan is slowly restoring
its nuclear capacity,
while Germany has increased
its renewable energy output
over the past decade, although that
was accompanied by a steep rise
in energy prices for the public.
For countries with nuclear
in their energy mix,
such as the UK, Finland, and China,
constructing efficient new reactors
is both expensive
and time-consuming.
Hinkley Point C, Britain's first
nuclear reactor since 1995,
will cost...
...at least twice as much
as the London 2012 Olympic Games,
and this figure continues to rise.
Modern nuclear reactors
are designed meticulously,
and built to withstand earthquakes
and other threats,
including plane crashes, but even
the best designed nuclear reactors
create radioactive waste,
and that needs careful disposal.
In the UK, we have about four
and a half million cubic metres
of radioactive waste.
The largest portion of this,
about 96%, is low-level waste.
High-level waste is
very high radioactivity material,
but we have the smallest volume
of this, just less than 1%.
The radiation from
high-level waste is so intense that,
if you were to touch it,
you'd receive a radiation dose about
a million times more than you would
receive throughout an entire year
just from natural radiation sources.
It's extremely high
for several thousands,
even hundreds of thousands of years,
so, ideally,
where we want to be is in a place
where we can isolate those wastes
from future populations
in a safe way -
for example,
digging a very deep hole underground
and disposing of the waste
there forever.
This solution is known as a...
...where waste is disposed of
between 200m and 1,000m
below the Earth's surface.
Because most people
don't like the idea
of living next to radioactive waste,
it's been very difficult
for governments to find a suitable
site, let alone start building one.
Finland is currently the only
country in the world building
a permanent underground storage
facility for their nuclear waste.
Every nation with nuclear power
has so far stored its waste
in temporary facilities,
and those facilities are ageing.
I'm not against deep disposal,
because I think ultimately,
we'll have to deal with
our present waste that way,
but that is so far ahead
that the problem here and now
is safe storage.
And all the time
we're waiting for the holy grail
of a deep disposal facility. The job
of that facility is to deal with
the massive amounts of nuclear
waste that we already have.
The idea that we should be
piling more and unknown quantities
for further ahead
is absolutely ludicrous, in my view.
If we don't get our hands on clean
energy and rapidly scale them up
by as much as possible
within the next few decades,
then we're leaving a massive,
massive burden
on future generations.
We need to completely decarbonise
the electricity sector,
and ideally also
the overall energy sector,
if we're to avert
the worst impacts
of the human-caused climate crisis.
As our understanding
of the climate crisis deepens,
and energy demands continue to grow,
the necessity that our energy
comes from non-fossil fuel sources
makes nuclear power hard to ignore.
It is expensive
and it can be dangerous
if safety protocols
are not followed.
The highly radioactive waste
it generates is hugely challenging
to store safely, but it also
provides a reliable power baseline,
keeping the lights from turning off
on a cloudy, windless winter evening
and meeting countries' energy needs
as they transition
away from fossil fuels.
And...